hello and welcome to this video here we
are mr. williger's again what do we do
the same utterly an uneventful cattle
online or is he going for something else
probably not he never goes for something
else one of the big danger is that I
will try to play quickly that I forget
forget what I'm actually playing them
through see it right I always have this
I mean I never really add I haven't
refreshed that red line for a long time
roop d1 Quincy seven and then see
success is the move
what's Otis now you're looking for big
novelties here or what's the what's the
deal you never get anything in their
line because there is nothing to get
yeah this is just a completely
completely equal position so the main
concern is as typical against this
person is the time I have to make sure
that I'm not getting into time travels
one that I get too ambitious this is the
main thing so yeah so I have to go on g6
here it's an interesting question
trading or not and on um I can actually
and it doesn't doesn't help 27 is also
move him but became problem taking is
not not bad
night is somewhat better here than the
end official in some cases and because
of the queenside pawns but as I have to
see file I don't think this is a big big
deal so what now I 55 is got 95
ok let's go here
now this is kind of endgame is always
something that can turn out to be a
little bit tricky yes my pawns a little
bit weak this is the thing and it's one
of those end games that he can play for
hours and anyway I was this wrong head
splits but you I think you get my drift
if you place rook 87 I have f5 f5 92
look-see to but aha so he had an idea
night comes to be 54 what goes here okay
you can check me here every night baby
bishop over to you one
night is just check tell if I go here it
looks a little bit annoying we don't
exactly see the problem here you Scott
checks so I'm going down you can go look
g7 King age 8 and then you can retreat
the look with a mate threat but I don't
see a particularly great square okay so
you
yeah he's again content with a
completely drawn ending check I could
have gone to h6 it doesn't matter
actually grah i heard I've got more time
on the clock here okay he might have
those two pods hmm yeah that was a
little bit in precise I didn't play that
very precisely check
and how very stupid very stupid claim
okay i have to have to give up the pawn
well now that i play pretty badly the
rook endgame is of course a complete
draw check now you can check twice and
then take age 6 yeah I'm actually making
it easy firm that's very bad check they
are very badly time warning
check I'm still fighting but it is it
should be a loss I go here and Kim g5
check rugby 7s rugby six
now that it's the key point is going to
promote check check check check check
check la nasa has a very bad and kim i
relaxed too early getting a little bit
pissed that he rejected the draw with 30
second down that was bad just
objectively very bad I should um yeah
it's a draw with with any decent normal
play not just how what I did for example
age five now is a pretty clear draw yeah
that's already bad i was i was too
relaxed i was too relaxed him after Jeff
I'd it gets tricky it already gets
tricky a little bit because I have no I
cannot easily dump the beep on for a
draw that kind of configuration three
against two is very good for him and um
yeah I did defended this very badly he i
should play g5 that was playing too
quickly i just played too quickly heaven
sent him
yeah i can probably can i do this this
may be for drawing others at five okay
that's at five what is the cleanest way
here it still should be a draw
would like to trade him but I'm not sure
about this move check lads it's not a
clean draw look look so clean maybe it
is if i do this i mean this this is not
really looking like he has to do this
and ok this is a draw mmm yeah this is
this is something that i actually always
should get but didn't get in the game i
really play the terribly that was bad
and allowing g5 was bad I really played
badly and just far too quickly I should
have thought a little bit to you how to
how to actually draw the position I
didn't question that this is I mean our
thinking I would get the drawer the
medical m and this is wrong yeah this is
already here I should go age five and T
I'm just losing that was completely
mindless very bad very bad I can still
go hear that same and and try to play
that even though it's already clearly
yeah it clearly went went downhill from
the get-go they absolutely easiest is to
go age five this is this is completely
completely drawn he's tied to that porn
is the problem if he what is he supposed
to do and it's totally enough for me if
I can trade down here against if I be if
I lose this and trade some ponds iam I'm
drawing this the bee pollen is
completely worthless it's not like this
porn is this doing me any good I mean
you could argue that I could push the
pond I mean yeah maybe I can push the
pawn forward it's something that
actually could have done yeah but it is
nothing this kind of thing you know this
is this is not helping me I don't have a
check end it's it's okay i just have to
second rank is ok and now i justjust go
age fire this is some thing pretty clear
you cannot move the f porn and what is
he doing like this i go here and tongue
yeah he cannot play g44 he can go
something i can do something like that
check and hope to hope to take this
later but how are you winning here I
guess you are not young yeah this is the
cleanest wrong hmm yeah I'm pretty bad
yeah I relax too early I simply relax
too early I mean he's a good end game
player I mean yes this rook against rook
those stupid stuff but he's a really
good end game play and I should have
thought there for a moment to really am
to really hold the draw on the board and
not just play some random quick moves
okay well thanks for watching